the forecasts are published and
available outside the press room and
without further ado I hand over to you
bourgeois yes good morning everybody
here are the main messages from the
interim summer forecast for 2019 and
2020 their interim because you know it's
more than once a year that we publish
forecasts twice a year we present
figures on gross that's what we're
concentrating on I'm giving you the next
forecasts you'll be getting my successor
giving you the the next round in
November first of all European economy
is beginning to stand or it's resisting
an environment which isn't so favorable
this is yeah
groans consecutively uh suppose that
Member States were on course to post
positive growth rates this is really to
change some people's negative feel
feelings in the eurozone growth should
slow down one point two this year one
point for next year compared to the
spring forecast this forecast is
unchanged for 2019 and slightly below 20
20 G DP EU 1.4% 2019 one point six
percent in 2020 the internal demands
should be the driver of growth in 2019
2020 it's supported by quite comfortable
monetary conditions this will last some
time the the messages of the ECB are
positive this expansionist policy in
some countries and there's good
good situation on the job from it
the euro area things have gone well and
a second message growth was a positive
surprise
the first water now we think this will
be a counterbalance by us falling off of
gross in the second half of the year a
couple of sectors which hit hard
external trade and manufacturing third
message
we've slightly brought down our and
revised down inflation forecasts so 1.3
2019 and 2020
the oil price will probably go down and
then there's lag in passing on of wage
increases to underlying inflation so we
have uncertainty in the world we know
this there growing trade tensions so
there are quite significant risks when
it comes to all our forecasts and of
course factors can extend the slowdown
in world trade the risk premium may
flare up in the world I'll try and
develop a few points now the first
quarter was vigorous there were
temporary factors though build-up of
stocks in the UK for the first brexit
date it's sensible to have buffer stocks
mild winter good for construction new
vehicle sales were good after the slack
in the second half of 2018 these are
factors which are temporary factors
probably they will fall off in the
second in the second quarter we've got
some information coming through already
on climate of confidence and some of the
more recent news is less positive so we
expect that the growth will be slowing
down in figures with second water the
more moderate growth rate will continue
in the second part of the year falling
in manufacturing is probably not hit the
bottom yet trades outlook is not good
because of the rise of protectionism and
tensions between the US and China okay a
truce
maybe in the air but this isn't
everything now household expenditures
keeping up a dynamic labor market energy
prices going down tax measures were
favorable in some countries in 2019
money's cheap this will probably
continue and that supports investment
ECB's recently extended the period
during which it reckons it will keep low
or very low interest rates now in spite
of stabilization of world growth in the
first quarter bounced economies are
pulling this on but their general
dynamics of the world economy a fairly
slack there's slowdown in manufacturing
and trade and has been continuing for
all sorts of reasons the growth
prospects for the world economy outside
the EU are weak and have weakened since
the spring that is a graphic histogram
which shows us the overall indicator for
purchasing directors as he hits rock
bottom
activity economic activity in the world
will keep up because of cheap money not
only in Europe but elsewhere
but also China is trying to relaunch the
economy but all these support factors
won't counterbalance the negative
effects of trade
tensions and economic tension so we
reckon that world's GDP Xu will slow
down 3.8 in 2018 3.4 in 2019 it might
pick up very moderately in 2020 to 3.6
now trade disagreements and
uncertainties weigh on GDP at a world
level in the last quarter of 2018 and
the first quarter of this year the
volume of world imports outside EU have
gone down so there's a deceleration of
world trade growth we reckon we'll be
slowing last year from from 4 points
while if last year was 4.7 now 7 to 1.6
the lowest figure since 2016 much lower
than the spring forecast slowed down
world economy disproportionately
negative impact on the eurozone in 2018
because you know we are a very open
economy but the geographical spread of
our exports actually have been more
favorable this year you can see that
world import excluding years and went
down by North point 6 percent in the
first quarter although the euro zone's
export markets went up by 1.1 percent of
the same period ok we'll see about
tensions the growth and trade outside
the EU we hope should leaders leavening
out to the battery a sense
happens at the global level domestic
survey data point to protracted weakness
in the manufacturing sector while the
service sector remains relatively busy
in particular the European Commission's
economic sentiment indicator shows a
continued deterioration in industry
confidence since the beginning of 2018
while confidence in services moved
sideways in recent months the difference
between both indicators is now the
highest since the financial crisis the
euro area Purchasing Managers indices
point to the same conclusion the
resonance of a domestic demand to
challenging external conditions
partially explains the dichotomy between
a resilient services sector and a
declining manufacturing activity it also
illustrates the challenges faced by the
European economy as protracted weakness
in manufacturing may start to spill over
to services that is one of the question
marks for next years now I move to
inflation inflation in the euro area
remains as I said very low the inflation
rate averaged 1.4 percent in the first
half of 2019 and in our view is set to
ease further in the second half on the
back of lower oil prices overall our
forecast for headline inflation in the
euro area is as I said slightly revised
down from 1.4 percent in spring to 1.3
percent both in 19 and 20 a core
inflation the inflation which excludes
energy and processes food prices remain
even lower
despite solid which grows and we have to
be robust private consumption grows
thanks to positive labour market
developments growth in compensation per
employee is relatively high compared to
historical
standards yet firms are not fully
translating higher labor cost in their
selling prices instead they seem to be
absorbing higher wages at the cost of
their profits rather than increasing
prices while this is good sake good news
for the purchasing power of households
the subdued demand outlook and elevated
uncertainties may ample investment
growth as I mentioned in my introduction
and I move to the growth map the economy
of each member state is expected to grow
in 2019 so we don't expect recession
anywhere the gross map however continues
to show quite different seasons across
the EU with most central and eastern
european economy is growing faster than
coleman the state's robust domestic
demand issued by the dynamic wage growth
and the absorption of EU funds they're
useful is helping to cushion these
central and eastern economies from the
slowdown of their main trading partners
on the other hand Germany and Italy are
at the center of the current softy patch
the German economy which as everybody
knows is obviously partly exposed to the
foreign trade and manufacturing witness
rebounded in first quarter of this year
thanks to a normalization of automotive
sales it is however unlikely to sustain
this stronger momentum in the following
quarters as we observe the cooling of
economic sentiment that has deepened in
recent months in contrast to depressed
foreign demand industrial output
domestic demand in Germany is proving
resilient this is spurred by solid wage
growth and unemployment at a record low
so overall growth in Germany is expected
to reach
0.5 percent in 2019 but to come up to
point four percent in 2020 driven partly
by a higher number of working days next
year and predicated on the assumption
that global demand will gradually
strengthen in Italy growth has been
under pull for more than four a few
quarters now the country left the
technical recession in the first quarter
of this year but is expected to have
stagnated in the second quarter
amid challenging external environment
economic activity is not likely to
rebound meaningfully before the end of
this here this rebound is largely
expected to rest on private consumption
backed by lower energy prices and the
new citizenship income scheme for
low-income earners overall the Italian
economy is forecast to expand by 0.1
percent this year before picking up to
0.7 percent in 2020 also helped by a
higher number of working days which is
the case everywhere in Europe all false
that was sort of a somatic in France
growth is expected to be maintained
compared to previous terms so one point
for next year
weakening of external demand will
obviously have an impact on economic
activity but internal demand should be
the main driver of French growth there's
also favorable conditions on the French
employment market and tax measures have
led to increase purchasing powers for
families and that should be translated
into a gradual increase in expenditure
or spending which was an expected
outcome in the first quarter is likely
to have persisted in the second quarter
as a result a forecast for GDP growth
this year has been revised up to 2.3
percent in 2020 economic expansion is
still forecast to east to a 1.9 percent
employment growth should slow down but
continue to expand robustly allowing for
further
actions in the unemployment rate which
is obviously good news for this country
which had a very important unemployment
rate together with wage increases is
should support disposable income growth
in the UK and stop piling and other
actions taken by businesses to mitigate
the uncertainties over the date and the
nature of the country's exit from the EU
supported growth in the first quote the
opposite is set to have happened in the
second quarter when these actions are
wound based on a purely once more
technical assumption of status quo in
terms of trading relations between the
EU and UK GDP is forecast to grow by 1.3
percent this year and also next year
private consumption is set there too to
be the main growth driver this year
while business investment growth is
expected to remain weak as British
related uncertainty persists next year
an improvement in net trade is expected
to offset store domestic demand growth
but of course there uncertainties we
don't know today when what will happen
the economic outlook I want to really
insist on that remains subject to a
number of interconnected downside risks
which one an extended us-china
confrontation and together with elevated
and certainty around US trade policy
could protract the current downturn in
global trade and manufacturing with the
possible negative impact on other
regions and sectors fears about such
developments could also trigger a shift
in a global risk sentiment at times when
valuations appear stretched across many
asset classes and this could lead to
rapid tightening of global financial
conditions with knock-on effects on some
vulnerable emerging markets second
series of risks risk related to the
recent intensification of geopolitical
tensions in the Middle East
with a potential significant impact of
all prices on the domestic front
persisting policy uncertainty protracted
weakness in manufacturing and downbeats
business confidence I could start
weighing more severely on the services
sector and the dichotomy we observe
might vanish this would weigh on
investment and employment and undermine
the resilience of domestic demand
finally a forecast again prepared under
technical assumption of status quo in
trade relations between the EU and UK
and any failure to secure a smooth
breath seat would of course impact
economic growth although more so in the
UK than in the rest of the EU so to
conclude and to sum up this summer
forecast shows a European economy
continue to expand against difficult
global backdrop all EU countries are
said to grow again in boost 19 and 20
what strong labor market is supporting
demand however given the numerous risks
to the outlook we must certainly
intensify our efforts to further
strengthen the resilience of our
economies and of the Europe area as a
whole this is why your career reforms
are more necessary than ever and need to
be really ambitious policy and okay and
I'm happy to answer any questions
Malanda in the hispaniola
I'm from Hispaniola I'd like to know if
the economic situation in Spain is of
concern to you what do you think about a
possible coalition government between
the Socialists and podemos and what will
the economic impact be of new elections
in November or next year the
Commissioner well it's almost five years
now that I will have been in this
job and so I've been taking questions
like this for five years now what's
happening here what you think if there's
elections if there aren't elections what
if and for five years I've been given
the same answer now basically that what
if is one of those questions that I
don't respond to I don't answer so
basically I think there will be a robust
response to the economic situation
whatever that may be and I think that
our outlook is based on solid data and I
think that it's clear that the Spanish
economy is really doing better and Spain
has continued to make progress to move
forward and I'm pleased about that
rated E radically Lucas Europe
two questions if I mean firstly you said
that Italy has been underperforming for
a few trimesters known for a few
quarters given the uncertainty
surrounding the government and policies
and discussions that were held in
December and recent months and that has
had an impact is having an impact on
Italian growth I mean what's your view
on that then in the outlook you say that
for the 2020 growth expectations there
are risks also linked to budget policy
which would be particularly challenging
next year what does that mean does that
mean that the government's tax measure
is that they will be putting in place
will have a negative impact on growth
well it's very complicated to measure
the specific impact of a particular
measure on growth but the only comment
that I could make
is that the world there were forecasts
of 1.7% by the French but sorry by the
Italian government and then last
September when there was an overview I
think at that time the general consensus
for 2019 was around 1% and today that's
dropped to 0.1% so I think if you look
at those trending in forecasts I think
we can conclude that things didn't quite
go as positively as I'd been expected in
some quarters and I mean the rolls it's
a cause and effect relationship but it's
always difficult to measure but I think
above all what's needed is well Italy
does need reforms they need to
strengthen productivity and that will
involve a huge effort from all sides now
I wouldn't be satisfied with the
response that you often hear in Italy
that systematically there's an
underperforming but uh I think that's
not good enough what there has to be
reforms and there needs to be
discussions with the Italian government
and I think one of the last tasks of
this commission will be to look at the
amended draft budget and to look at how
reliable there that would be and I think
it's no secret that there is intense
dialogue and positive dialogue with the
Italian government from December 2018
will right through to today I think that
to be
well in I think we have to be clear and
have to world you could say third time
lucky I think you have to keep trying to
improve and to do what needs to be done
and I think that that will mean that we
it will be possible to have a budget
which will promote growth
ethyl esters with CNA Commissioner you
read here that you have identified the
fragile nature Reese's recovery and you
also see some previews forecasts dangers
and risks to materialize could you
please elaborate on those risks that are
materializing right now in the current
forecast and furthermore since you're
counting inland you're factoring the
positive let's say implications of the
policy measures the fiscal policy
measures from the previous government
are you also calculating the potential
impact of the readjustment measures that
are going to be needed for the economy
to go back to the original trajectory
are you calculating also the measures
needed readjust the path next I'm not
going to command the civilians report
that was discussed yesterday and the day
before in the Eurogroup and take afine
we know that we appointed that the risk
of not meeting the three point five
percent target has increased but our
focus for Greece has been revised
slightly downwards photos of 19 from 2
point 1 to 12 2.1%
two point two to two 12.1 and the first
quarter of 2019 Greece's economy showed
signs of the slowdown as year-on-year
growth decreased to 1.3 percent from 1.5
percent in the previous quarter
and this Troodon was driven mainly by
the external sector and the declining
public consumption while investment
shows sign of revival which is
encouraging and private consumption grew
at a moderate rate policy measures
adopted in May 19 are expected to give a
short time short-term boost to the
economy however a lasting recovery
remains heavily contingent on the
continuing implementation of reforms
inflation will remain subdued in 19 and
20 due to lower energy prices Matt no
yeah
now this new government in Greece and
in June 2018 there were commitments
given to the Eurogroup and any proposal
will have to be discussed within that
group now obviously we're entering into
a new phase now forming a government and
the democratic process in Greece has to
be fully respected so I'm not going to
speculate on anything today I had a talk
with the people this morning ministers
and
you
I also spoken to some of the advisors
and I've conveyed my congratulations on
the new government and I look forward to
having positive constructive talks I
mean even when there was austerity in
Greece I mean I think relations with the
Commission have always been good and
either this month or later or at some
point be it here in Brussels or in
Greece but I think in the very near
future we'll be engaging with this the
new government and look forward to
positive constructive engagement and
talks with Greece and within the context
of the euro zone as well
and I think one of the trademarks as it
were of the current commission is that
approach now obviously we have to
continue to work and to try and ensure
that the Greek economy is a success
and the Swiss couple delicious
prosperity' commissioner in your
forecast for Poland for some years
already you underlined the the problem
with the rule of law will somehow
undermined the the economy growth
because they will lead to the decrease
of trust of businesses you know as far
as the judicial independence
independence is concerned this is
something that you're repeating in all
your in all your Erika's but you know in
this forecast we see that apart from
Malta Poland and Hungary are the fastest
growing growing economies in the EU so
I'm just wondering whether do you think
it will take more time for you know
these problems in with the rule of law
to translate into the economic
weaknesses or simply this link is not
it's not it's not real and a second
question if my if I may as you mentioned
yourself it could be I we are not sure
yeah but this might be your last press
conference devoted you know to the to
the economic forecast I'm just wondering
whether you have any advice for your
successful thank you
I'm not saying that's my last press
conference for ever here but the
tradition is that generally even if
there is a second mandate I don't know
about that you're not the same portfolio
so that's why I can say that with some
certainty the rest does not belong to me
to my successor would certainly but
we'll do that one is over when he or she
is in place recommend to continue having
quite firm rigorous but also intelligent
and flexible implementation of the rules
of the pact that's what we did during
those five years and finally I think
this is more success than a failure I'm
happy that we were capable of as well
when you sing strongly deficits all over
Europe especially in euro area and on
the other hand not to sanction any
country and through dialogue to move to
agreements which were leading to
compliance with the
stability and growth pact and I think
this is the right way to proceed and I
hope this will be continued of course
each commission as its own style
each Commission and its own guidance not
interfering in that I think that that
direction proved to be a successful as
far as polling is concerned as you know
GDP growth is forecast Gregory moderate
from five point one percent in 2018 to
four point four percent in eighteen and
three point six in twenty which are
still quite impressive results but it's
clear that in the long run
the confidence in the country depends
also on the rule of law thank you very
much any other questions for the
Commissioner Jim
thank you thank you very much Jim
Bronstein from the Financial Times
given that the slowdown in Germany has
such a major impact on the overall
numbers for the euro area how satisfied
are you that the German government is
taking the right kind of measures and
enough action to try to stimulate
domestic demand and otherwise reinforced
the economy I want to add one point to
the year previous answer is that in the
impressive growth forecast for as well
Poland in central and eastern countries
there is very strong impact of the
structural funds and this is also
something that might be who knows linked
to the respect of the rule of law we
must not forget that and that's why it's
I think important to stay together in a
union with common values and also shared
approach of a rule of law and this is a
point that everybody must keep in mind
another habit that I have is never to
comment on measures taken by a
government but only to appreciate
forecasts and results I think that in
Europe and especially in the eurozone we
have common rules and we have a common
approach and we have a common spirit but
there is also some freedom of the means
and so I'm not going to comment on
German governance from positions you
know that our approach and I had the
occasion to repeat that yesterday in the
echo Finland the day before in your
group when commenting the European
fiscal board report by Nielsen and his
colleagues is that we certainly need to
look very closely not only to the
overall fiscal stance of the eurozone
but also to its geographical composition
and I record then that I still believe
that those countries which have high
deficits and a risk of
that rising need clearly to make further
efforts but that other countries with
high surpluses need to make symmetrical
efforts in order to reinforce investment
afford their own sake and for the sake
of the growth of the eurozone
thank you very much commissioner I'm
coming back to the Spanish corner here
and a friend a token from confidentiel
back in in autumn you said that the
deployment worth in his pain was
expected to slow down in part because of
the increase of the of the minimum wage
after these months I don't know if you
could please explain us if you still
think that this increase in the minimum
wage has an impact on the unemployment
rose or if you think that finally that
impact has not been realized everything
is in the fears
your ass do we have any other questions
or that was it thank you very much
commissioner for your time thank you for
coming along again the press material is
outside and all available online thank
you and the readout midday will start
soon